hello and thank you for joining us for
this NCBI now my name is sherry Holland
Bailey from NCBI customer services and
today we will learn how to tailor your
PubMed search experience using my NCBI
we'll begin by highlighting search terms
which makes it easier to scan your
results customize search filters to
narrow results and conclude by
permanently displaying up to 200 records
per page so let's get started with
highlighting for today's example I'm
using my free newly created NCBI account
that can be accessed directly from
PubMed as a side note if you're already
logged in to your NCBI account you can
return to the my NCBI home page by
clicking on the my NCBI link located
beside your username or the top right or
you may wish to access your NCBI account
directly with the following URL now that
I'm logged into my NCBI home page I will
click NCBI site preferences located
beneath the blue toolbar into the right
beneath common preferences click
highlighting and a pop-up window will
allow you to select your favorite
highlighting color and then click Save
a confirmation of the changes can be
seen both here and here let's return to
PubMed where I've created a search for
asthma notice the term asthma is
highlighted in number four because it
appears in the title although my search
term does not appear in one two or three
you can see here my term does appear in
keywords and multiple times in the
abstract this allows me to quickly scan
and determine if this article could fit
my research needs now let's set our
filters filters exist in narrowing down
search results to smaller groups of data
for example I'm doing extensive research
with the most recent publications
dealing with adolescent chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease or COPD I
use filters to sort through the
thousands
citations in PubMed to target the most
relevant results for my research a quick
word about filters you are allowed the
maximum of 15 filters within PubMed to
get started you may wish to select from
category and your choices include
popular the most common requested
filters link out which groups resources
provided by outside organizations
properties which group records according
to specific criteria such as age human
or animals and male or female and
finally links which links to other NCBI
databases at your convenience I
encourage you to fully explore the
predefined PubMed shelters for the sake
of time I have selected a few filters
from categories 1 selected the filters
will appear in your PubMed filter list
column please note that any filter that
you wish to be active requires you to be
logged into your NCBI account and will
be active as long as the box is checked
as previously mentioned I'm interested
in adolescent COPD although standard
filters are useful they do not always
capture every soldier in need this is a
job for custom filters once you click
create custom filter a pop-up window
will appear here is where you will enter
the term or terms to create the
customized filter in my example I have
entered terms that will locate items
referring to COPD as Excel adolescence
than were published in the year 2017 you
may have noticed the bracketed DT D P is
a pubmed field description tag for those
who are new to description tags or need
a refreshment a great tutorial is linked
at the bottom of the screen you will
also be able to find it in additional
materials post it at the end of this
presentation next I will test my query
and based on the initial results I may
decide to further broaden or narrow it
now it's time to create a name for the
filter
I've taken the guesswork out of what a
filter does by naming it COPD and lesson
2017 once complete click Save soldier
custom filters will not automatically be
active they must be selected custom
filters may be removed by clicking the
delete link also predefined filters may
be removed by unchecking the appropriate
box in the active column you may also
edit custom filters at any time by
clicking the gear modifying your query
and save filter now that I have all of
my filters in place let's take a look at
how it appears in PubMed notice I still
have my search term asthma and to the
right are my customized filters in the
parentheses show the total number of
items available based on my search of
asthma which is seen in all if and my
search result I'm interested in only
free full-text I will click the
corresponding link notice that you can
quickly manage your filters by clicking
on the manage filter splink which will
redirect you to the filters page in my
NCBI now that we have created filters we
are also able to quickly activate
deactivate modify and manage filters
from the my NCBI home page without the
extra step of my NCBI site preferences
so a quick recap so far we have learned
how to highlight search terms create
modify activate and use filters and now
we will learn to permanently display up
to 200 records in the pubmed page once
you click results display setting a
pop-up window will appear select the
desired number of results per page and
click Save now that the results have
been saved
let's see it in action I can verify the
amount of items per page in two places
the name search results and beside per
page you may also
temporarily change the default by using
the drop-down box next to per page these
are just a few of the ways to tell your
PubMed experience thank you for joining
us and please feel free to ask any
remaining questions at this time okay
thank you right now I don't see any
questions that we haven't already
answered in the chat pod when we go
ahead and go on to the next slide which
has the help document lengths on we can
talk about those a little bit okay so
here's a slide that has more information
there some URLs here that will give you
some more help using PubMed search field
tags and other things about my NCBI be
sure to check out our blog at NCBI
insights that in CDI LM NIH gov and make
sure you check out our YouTube channel
and remember that you can write to us at
the help desk at info at NCBI NLM to NIH
cup okay thanks everybody for coming and
we'll see you next time
you